MALE SPEAKER: So good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to another outstanding
Authors at Google talk.
Today we're pleased to host
a Mike Marriner and the
co-founders of the Roadtrip
Nation organization.
What is Roadtrip Nation,
you may ask?
It's outstanding example
of a dream that,
actually, never dies.
It keeps on going.
So back in college, Mike
and his friends went
on this road trip.
They interviewed a few people.
They posted some
videos online.
It became this long
going tradition.
And one road trip leads to
another, leads to another and,
in this case, leads
to a company.
So not only do they have a PBS
series that was picked up,
detailing their adventures,
but they have a foundation
that encourages high school
and college kids to start
their own road trip to really
explore their own communities.
And so they'll tell us what
they're up to, most recently.
And we'll also play a video.
So Mike, did you want to talk
about video, briefly.
MIKE MARRINER: Sure.
I guess we'll begin the story
with the end in mind and show
a little bit of a video, of a
snapshot of what Roadtrip
Nation is today, from one of
our recent series on public
television.
So we'll just kick it
off with this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-On your tombstone, at the end
of the day, they're going to
see three things.
They're going to see
your birth date.
They're going to
see that dash.
And they're going to see
your death date.
The front and the back,
they're done.
But the thing that has
the most importance
to me is that dash.
What happened in your life
during the time you were born
to the time you passed away?
What defines you as a person?
-Hi, I'm with Roadtrip Nation.
-And we're going to traveling
across the
country for six weeks.
-From the West Coast to the
East Coast in an RV.
-And interviewing people
whom we believe
followed their passions.
-And meet with people that are
in really interesting places.
-We're kind of at a loss for
what we should do, so hoping
to talk to the people who do
things that we really look to.
-I feel like I'm just spinning
my wheels right now.
I'm ready to catch
something and go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Where were you when
you were our age?
-What fears or anxieties
did you have?
-I really was like you.
I didn't know what
I wanted to do.
But I wanted to see
what's out there.
-We travelled in a school
bus, tattooing
all over the country.
-I was a messenger boy.
Whatever it takes to pay your
rent so you can act.
-I was really lost.
I was either going to end up
pregnant or in jail or dead or
I was going to be able
to change my life.
-It feels so good, I think, to
look into your motivations and
your apprehensions.
-I mean it sounds silly to say
you profit from your mistakes,
but you do.
I mean, when you make a mistake,
and you go in the
wrong direction, it will
help you somewhere.
-I am nervous about taking
a step into the unknown.
-And it's a call on what
you see as failure.
Never doing what I wanted
to do is failure to me.
-It's a huge roller
coaster, right?
It can be high times, low times,
happy times, sad times.
And you just have to hang on.
-Never give up on your dreams,
no excuses, Kyle Maynard.
[COWS LOWING]
-Oh my gosh.
-What?
-We're surrounded by cows.
-This has like been the
most surreal place
I've ever been to.
America is so big.
There are a million experiences,
and there are a
million thoughts that you
can think, and a million
definitions that can be added to
who you are and how you see
yourself in the world.
-Your heart is like
a GPS system.
The GPS system in your car will
tell you which way to go,
but it's not going to turn
your car for you.
If your heart's telling
you to turn left,
you better turn left.
And there are a lot of people
who wait too late to listen to
their heart.
-Every single person
has a story.
And every person came
from somewhere.
-I have these ideas of what
I want in my life
and all these things.
But no one ever knows what's
going to be coming up ahead.
And it could change
everything.
And it could be better than
you even expected it.
-I just can't wait to see
what the next few
weeks have in store.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN MCALLISTER: So we wanted
to kick off with some footage.
As you guys will learn to
know, we're not really
motivational speakers.
We really don't bring a lot of
the drive to our presentation.
So I think a big part of
it is just sharing
stories from the road.
And I think that's what we
really wanted to engage you
guys with was some of the
stories that we've been
aggregating, over the past 12
years, now, and share, with
you guys, where Roadtrip Nation
started out and what it
has become.
Because, as you can see from
this trailer, we're in our
10th season on public
television.
We've had an opportunity
to write three books.
We've been sending thousands
of students on road trips
throughout the United
States and,
actually, around the world.
And what we want to share with
you guys is some of the
findings and some of the
discoveries that we have
collected through these
experiences.
But we're very much on the
back end of things.
We usually are behind
the scenes.
And so the three of us,
actually, don't get a lot of
opportunities to share the
stories that we've had along
the journey.
So that's probably kind of what
we hope to get out of it.
And we're all about Q&A. And so
we'll open it up at the end
of this to answer some
questions, to engage some
conversations.
MIKE MARRINER: So everyone
always asks like, how did
Roadtrip Nation start?
Was it a business plan?
Was it some kind of
post-doctoral thesis or
something like that?
But it it's actually
none of that.
It was really just Nate, Brian,
and I being in school
and wondering, what do we want
to do with our lives?
And we started to realize
there's no class in school to
help you figure out what do you
want to do with your life.
We though that was kind of
funny, because there's all
these classes for math and
English and science.
Those are, obviously, really
important things.
But we felt the big elephant in
the room was, well, what do
you want to do with your life?
And so when we asked our
teachers this, they said, go
talk to your school counselor.
Maybe they can help you figure
out what do you want to do
with your life.
And so we went to
our counselor.
And the counselor told us, OK,
take, I think, it was the
Myers-Briggs test or something
like that.
You fill in some dots.
And we were like, seriously?
NATHAN GEBHARD: I was supposed
to be a plumber.
That was the big finding.
I should be a plumber.
MIKE MARRINER: So, essentially,
at that point, we
really felt, intuitively, that
we needed something more
exploratory, something
more humanized.
And so that's when
we had the idea.
It wasn't as much to create
Roadtrip Nation, as it was,
what if we could hit the road
and go talk to people who are
doing interesting things, all
across America, and ask them,
how did you get to where
you are today?
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think it
really came in this real
visceral sense.
I remember being in college and
passing my resume out at a
career fair.
I was a business major.
And so it was like a little
assembly line.
Business majors at the school
I was at become consultants.
And so I was passing my resume
out to like, Arthur Andersen,
all these different companies.
And I remember handing my resume
to a guy and saying
like, I have no idea what you
do or what I'm applying for.
What is this thing?
And I remember taking him
out to lunch one day.
And I was like, I just need to
see what this things about,
that I'm applying for.
And I remember getting
to lunch.
And he had a suit and tie on.
And I waited politely
for a while.
And I was like, so do you have
to wear the suit all the time?
And he was really fired
up about it.
He was like, yeah, you
get to dress nice.
They give you a budget
for clothes.
And the blood just completely
drained out of my body.
I could just instantly, in
that one simple moment,
realize that this whole path
that I was put on, to make
money and get that mortgage
and be a professional, was
just kind of falling apart at
the simplest thing of like, I
can't wear a suit every day.
I think we, each of us, had that
freak out moment, where
we really realized we needed to
see what else was out there
and what we were
interested in.
BRIAN MCALLISTER: And
I think so much of
it was lack of exposure.
Like to Nate's point, we
didn't really know
what was out there.
And to what Mike was saying,
you take these tests, these
assessment tests, and Nate
figures out he's going to
become a plumber.
But we really needed something
more human.
There was almost like a
frustration that, at the end
of the day, we just wanted to go
out and talk to people from
all walks of life and ask
them, how did you get
to where you are?
Was there ever a time in your
life that, perhaps, you're
going through a period of
ambiguity, or you were
displaced, or you just weren't
sure where the next step was?
Or how did you identify those
values within and see that?
And how did you align
a lifestyle or a
culture to a job?
And I think these were some
of the questions we were
challenging with.
And it wasn't like academia
was bringing this to us.
As you guys know, a lot of cool
projects sometimes start
in a garage.
This project was started
out in a motor home.
So we bought my parents old,
beat-up motor home.
The thing barely ran.
I mean, Nate and I--
NATHAN GEBHARD: It
didn't matter.
BRIAN MCALLISTER: We pretty
much fixed the thing as we
travelled across the
United States.
And this was our vehicle.
This was our space.
So this thing was an old,
beat-up motor home.
We painted it green, because
the paint was on
sale at Home Depot.
I mean we were funding this
thing through credit cards.
It wasn't like we had some agent
behind us that was like,
hey, we're going to make you
guys some reality show on MTV.
It was very, very sincere
and authentic.
And we started just to question
like, who's out there
doing creative things?
Who's out there really
changing the world?
Where are some of these
change agents?
And let's ask them, like,
what's driving them?
And so that's what led us to
the people that we actually
ended up interviewing.
We booked over 85 interviews.
We got denied, probably,
500 times, 1,000 times.
And we found these people
through magazine articles,
different subscriptions that
we're applying, magazines.
We were combing through
mastheads.
We found ourselves at newspaper
stands just saying,
where are the cool people?
What are they doing?
And let's go talk to them and
ask them, how did you get to
where you are today?
NATHAN GEBHARD: And it was this
simple sense of I like
snowboarding, and I like art.
Well, what about the guys that
put that together, like the
art on snowboards?
And so like literally just cold
called Burton Snowboards
and said like can we talk
to somebody there?
I'm kind of a tech geek.
I was watching TV, and there
was a Dell commercial.
And I got the 1-800
number off the
commercial to buy a computer.
And I just asked for Michael,
Michael Dell.
And it was about six transfers
later, and I ended up speaking
to Laura Strange, who was
overseeing all of his
communications.
And six months after that, he
was just sitting shotgun in
the actual, original RV.
But it was literally just cold
call, no connections.
I cold called the Supreme Court
and asked for Sandra.
Mike ended up calling the
director of "Saturday Night
Live" every three days, for
three months straight, until
she finally picked up the phone
on the stage for the MTV
Music Videos Awards
or something.
MIKE MARRINER: Yeah.
It wasn't just like
high-up executives
or people like that.
It was a lobsterman from
the coast of Maine.
It was an environmental
activist in DC.
It was just people who--
how we defined it later is like
people who define their
own roads in life, which is
really the mission of Roadtrip
Nation today.
But over the course of 2 and
1/2 months, we drove over
15,000 miles in Brian's old,
family, beat-up motor home,
interviewed over 84 people.
And I think that's what we want
to do is show you guys a
little bit of a glimpse
of that road trip.
We ended up buying this old,
beat-up video camera.
None of us had any
film experience.
We weren't film majors,
anything like that.
But around that time,
video cameras were
getting pretty cheap.
So we ended up just filming
everything.
And we were able to then kind
of aggregate some of that
footage together, at the
end of that trip.
So here's a little glimpse into
one section of our road
trip, from, I think, about
Vermont down through Maine and
then into Boston.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-You can work hard, and you
can, hopefully, be good at
what you do.
But things like Burton, that's a
once in a lifetime deal that
somehow I happened to
hook up with a guy
that invented a culture.
I don't know.
I realized I sucked at math
and shit early on.
And I focused on art work.
And also punk music was going
off at that point.
It was all Clash, Sex Pistols,
Ramones was the whole program.
My first date, with my wife,
was the Clash, in Montreal.
So I went on that path.
I didn't have any calculated
route I was going to take.
Because my parents didn't have
a clue about that stuff.
My father worked in a factory
making cottage cheese.
And my mother was beautician
from Maine.
I think a lot of it is, as you
guys are trying to prove here,
you really just have to go with
what you believe in and
what you really want to do.
Simon Woodruff said that the
world will conspire to support
you, if you really magnify what
it is you believe in.
People will rally around
you and help.
And I think you'll find that
from your family and your
friends and everything else, if
you decide you're going to
be a sculptor, if you decide
you're going to be an
architect, or you decide you're
going to be a kick-ass
accountant.
It's like, if you really believe
it, and you wear it on
your shoulder, and you really
do it with distinction, the
world will conspire to do it.
Distinction is everything.
You've got to be willing
to do that.
And if you look at any examples
of people that have
been successful in what they're
doing-- and not
monetarily successful,
successful in their life--
they are generally pretty
distinctive individuals.
And it's because they've got the
self-confidence to have a
point of view.
And I think that can be a
farmer in the boonies of
Vermont or Montana or something,
and it can be the
most progressive artist
in New York City.
But they will both have
self-confidence in what
they're doing, and they'll both
have a point of view.
They'll have a philosophy
that they'll back up.
Just do it with some fricking
balls, that's all I'd say.
I don't know.
There's so many people that
just have this sort of
milquetoast existence.
And they get frustrated that
they sort of get washed around
in the flow.
And it's like, you're doing
that to yourself.
That's where I'm at, at this
point, and what I'm trying to
inspire people here to do, that
you can do whatever the
hell you want.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-It's frightening to be making
decisions now, because you
feel like, OK, I'm going to make
a small decision now, and
that's probably going
to affect the way
my life pans out.
-What is the next step?
-Because I don't know.
And it scares me.
And I don't want to do something
that I hate.
But I also am afraid of taking
the serious risks that I think
involve not doing something
that I hate.
-I'm studying post-colonial
African-American migration
narratives.
-Holy.
-Wow.
-See.
-Can I get one of those?
Another one of those?
That was sweet.
-It looks like we'll go to
lunch with you guys.
-Where are you going?
-I don't know.
Where are you taking me?
-I want to go with you.
I'll like hop on this thing
right now, totally.
-Now that I think about it,
maybe the core of everything
is that I'm not believing
in myself.
-To some degree, I feel like the
path that I'm on has been
laid out for me, in some ways.
Sometimes I've had a kind of
crisis of, you now, is this
really what I'm supposed to do
or have people just told me
all the time that this
is what I want to do?
And is this it?
Is there something else?
-It's funny, actually, a bunch
of people have approached us,
over the years, my partner and
me, to write a book about the
history of Nantucket Nectars.
And I never really wanted to
write a book about the history
of Nantucket Nectars.
I wanted to write a book about
figuring out who I was.
-Cheers.
-To the New World.
-And there I was, living
on Nantucket.
And the first time I was out
there, I got my commercial
fishing license, because we'd
know other way to make money.
I wore these big, rubber boots
and the whole fishing outfit
and everything.
My parents came out there
a couple times.
And I'm sure they looked
at me and were like,
what is this kid doing?
-I had another kind of life.
It was the life of a traveling
vagabond, essentially.
I was traveling Europe and
having extraordinary, unusual
experiences, no question
about it.
-The last thing I had to do at
night was I'd have to wash out
all the buckets.
They had the shells and the
scallop guts in them.
And I'm on this back
dock, right
over the water, Nantucket.
And it's midnight.
And it was Christmas Eve.
And the water is, literally,
freezing on the
dock under my feet.
I didn't even notice it.
And all of a sudden, I turned
and feet come out from
underneath me.
I slam on the dock.
The hose is shooting
up in the air.
I'll never forget this, just
sitting there, looking up in
the sky, thinking, what
the hell am I doing?
I mean, what am I doing?
I'm washing out guts out of a
scallop bucket on Christmas
Eve in Nantucket.
I'm 23 years old.
I went to Brown.
I mean, I should be doing
something different.
My parents are pissed at me.
Well, I ended up living on
Nantucket for four more years
and building this business.
And even two or three years
into Nantucket Nectars, my
parents were like, starting
a juice company?
I mean, are you kidding me?
What do you mean you're
starting a juice?
Who starts a juice company?
-I heard a very funny story,
when I was nine.
I wrote some compositions, as
kids do, I just wrote these
little things.
And my mother put them
in for an arts
festival, in our village.
Everybody in England, every
villager has an arts festival.
And the time came for giving
out the awards and prizes.
And he held my compositions
above his head.
And he said, these compositions
are so bad, that
not only can I not consider
them for the competition--
that goes without saying--
but this young man should
be discouraged from ever
composing again.
That's what he said.
-Wow.
-There's a million different
paths to get there.
And everyone thinks
there's one, when
they give you advice.
And there isn't one.
Could anyone have ever
predicted my path?
OK, this is how you're
going to make it.
What you do is--
you want to start
a juice company?
OK, this is how you do it.
You should move to Nantucket.
Start a boat business, end
up being a fisherman.
And then get into distribution
and start a juice business.
That's how you get into juice.
Like who would ever say that?
-So it's important to know
what you're after.
And then, if you know what
you're after, and you really
want it, then you don't look
around wondering whether
you're better or worse than the
next person, because it's
not about that.
It's about what you
want to do.
[SINGING - BEETHOVEN,
"ODE TO JOY"]
It's the "Ode to Joy"
of Beethoven.
[LAUGTHER]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE MARRINER: So that's just
a little glimpse into that
experience.
And like we said, we did 84
interviews, over 15,000 miles,
2 and 1/2, almost 3 months,
on the road.
And I think, over and over
again, everyone always tries
to boil down into one insight.
But we think that one of the
big, overarching things that
we found was this notion of
defining your own road life.
And especially at that age,
when you're growing up in
American culture, there's
all different types of
expectations, and things that
we heard a few of our people
on the road call, noise,
trying to influence the
decisions that we're making
around that time in your life
when you're trying to
figure out what you
really want to do.
And that was the overarching
theme that we found.
A lot of defining our own road
in life is about shedding that
noise and getting down to what
are the elements that really
make you who you are?
What are the things that are
your interests, your values,
the things that make
up the DNA and the
grain of who you are?
And how do you shed enough of
that noise to build your life
around those things that matter,
that matter the most?
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think one of
the things, for me, was said
by a guy named Randy Komisar.
He was the author of "The Monk
and the Riddle." And he said,
in perfect metaphor to our
experience, life is only
linear in the rearview mirror.
And I think, for me, that was
really instrumental, because I
had this expectation, from
family and friends, that you
had to, if you're interested in
art, and you wanted to be
creative, than you were likely
going to live under the
boardwalk, poor and homeless.
And I really, really
listened to that.
And that was what put me on the
path to study business and
go down that route.
And that's where, ultimately,
I felt hollow.
And it wasn't until we had done
this road trip, where I
was able to see that you could
take your interest in
something as odd as lobsters
or something as exciting as
snowboards and you can put
them together, maybe not
lobsters and snowboards.
But, for me, it design and
snowboards or design and
technology.
But you can mash these
things up.
It's not this like, sit on an
assembly line kind of approach
that I think we have, both in
our current mentality, as well
as the way in which we raise
our children in our
educational system.
So it freed my thinking
up to think that so
much more was possible.
And I think it was those voices
in my head that kept us
going through the adventure of
starting Roadtrip Nation after
the road trip.
BRIAN MCALLISTER: So it was
such a transformative
experience on the three of us
that we really came back from
this three and a half month
journey having a drive and a
desire to share.
We had a lot of friends that we
felt needed to hear some of
these stories and break down
some of their master plans or
even just provide perspective.
I think that was probably one
of the biggest things that I
took away, from being on this
journey, was just perspective
of identifying who you are
and how to align it.
You guys heard--
Jager's actually one most
influential interviews that we
had on that trip, as he just
talked about distinction.
And you've got to wear it on
your shoulder, and you've got
to be proud about it.
And I think we had the fear
of having this milquetoast
existence, that you
get washed around.
And I think like, coming back
from that journey was really
something that the three
of us went through.
But it was more of a
desire to share it.
What we wanted to share with
you guys is that original
trip, because it's rooted in
everything that we do now.
It really provided
the framework of
where we are today.
But it was definitely a long,
long journey of how we got
from that original road trip,
in an old, beat-up
motor home, to today.
MIKE MARRINER: So everyone
always asks that question.
We know you took Brian's old,
family RV, painted it green
and lived in it for
three months and
did that whole thing.
But how do it evolve into this
organization that has an
annual documentary series and
a nonprofit education
foundation that has curriculum
in schools across America and
all that stuff?
And think there's no
real clean answer.
I think the best way we can
describe is there was a very
incremental, evolutionary
process over a 10 year period.
And that we didn't go out and
get venture capital and scale
it over two years.
I mean it's something that we
did very incrementally and in
as organic and mission-based
a manner as we could.
And it really started with, on
that road trip, we had met
someone who was a writer
at "Forbes
Magazine," in New York City.
And she tagged along for some of
those interviews we did in
New York City, like Len Riggio,
from Barnes & Noble,
and "Saturday Night Live." and
she ended up doing a very
small article in "Forbes"
on Roadtrip Nation.
It was definitely not
a cover story.
It was literally two inches.
But it got a little
bit of attention.
And we learned that big New York
book publishers, if you
get an article in a magazine
like that, there's some
credibility.
So through a series of events,
we ended up getting a
publishing contract with
Random House's imprint
Ballantine Books.
And that's the book that's
in the back there.
But essentially, we had the
chance, for a year and a half
after that road trip, to write
a book about our experiences,
really reflect on some of the
content and the stories and
the insights we gained over
that experience and
release that book.
The book came out in 2003.
It didn't sell very
well at first.
It was like the 600,000th best
selling book in America.
And we were like, no big deal.
We had a great experience.
And then the publisher got
behind it and put us on this
major PR blitz.
And we were on CNN, "Carson Daly
Show," "Newsweek," NPR,
"Today Show." And the day we
were on the "Today Show", it
became 15th best selling book
in America on Amazon.
It was just for a day.
But we still claim it.
Mom and dad are proud.
But around that time, there was
lots of different kind of
energy for Roadtrip Nation,
Hollywood agents and MTV show
this, and blah, blah, blah.
And around that time, that's
when we really got intentional
with building a grassroots
organization that was
mission-based that could empower
other people to define
their own roads in life.
And one of the first steps that
we took was too launch a
series on public television by
first creating a program, on
college campuses, called "Behind
the Wheel," where
college students could apply for
the chance to go on these
annual summer road trips.
We had a few organizations that
got behind us to support
it and fund the production.
And over a period of 7 years,
we expanded to 350 college
campuses across America.
We created a fleet
of motor homes.
These trips went around
the world to
New Zealand, Australia.
There was Roadtrip Nation Israel
in Hebrew, Africa,
South America, all over.
And the movement proliferated
on a college level.
And the first three minute
overview that we showed you
was season seven from that.
And then the interesting thing
about this was that, over this
period of time, we chose to
go with public television,
because we could have a
mission-based approach, the
creative control.
But the interesting part was
that by doing that, public
television also allows you to
maintain the rights to all of
your content.
If we would have gone with like
an MTV or something, it
would have been gobbled
up by Viacom.
And we would have had
a salary from them.
But because it was public media,
we were able to then
build an independent
organization around it and
have some longevity.
So can you show the
content archive.
NATHAN GEBHARD: Yeah.
MIKE MARRINER: So, essentially,
now, 10 years
later, after doing Roadtrip
Nation and mobilizing this
movement of other student road
trips, not only were we
mobilizing these experiences to
impact the student's lives
who were participating and
creating this TV show and
whatnot, we were also creating
this enormous digital content
archive, which I don't think
we could have predicted the
power of from the beginning.
But, essentially, it's almost
like an ethnographic study.
Someone called it that
the other day.
But in terms of like, if you
did mobilize teams of road
trippers, for 10 years, to go
across America and across the
world and collect people's
personal stories, like a huge
oral history project, and just
ask them a simple question,
how did you figure out
what you wanted to
do with your life?
And what were the steps that
you've taken to get
where you are today?
And what are the insights
and lessons
learned along that journey?
Those are stories and insights
we've been collecting for the
past 10 years.
And that's what's really led us
into the new education work
we're dealing.
In 2008, we saw something really
interesting happening,
outside a little town in
Pittsburgh called Mon valley.
We'd been doing Roadtrip Nation,
as the college model,
in the PBS series, for
about five years.
And I think we're thinking
about, what's the next step
for Roadtrip Nation?
How can we spread this
impact further?
We were mobilizing several
green RV trips a
year, around the world.
But was there another model that
could be accessible to
more and more students,
especially students that are
growing up in communities where
they don't have a lot of
chances to explore or connect
with leaders and explore
what's possible for
their own futures?
And so, outside of Pittsburgh,
there was a little town called
Mon Valley, a school
district there.
And there was a lot of,
essentially, mining
jobs in that area.
But the mining industry
was drying up.
And the district was looking
for a way to engage their
students and show them that
there's a whole world of
possibilities for
their future.
In short, they were looking
for a project, a career
exploration project based
learning activity.
And our documentary series was
airing on prime time in WQED.
And some of the leadership in
the school district there
said, we've got an idea.
Let's do a Roadtrip Nation
Western Pennsylvania.
And let's localize it.
And this is when things really
got interesting.
Because it showed us that you
really don't need a green RV
or a cross-country trip
to have the impact
from Roadtrip Nation.
When you really strip it away,
the impact was always about
these conversations that were
happening on the road, the
people that you meet.
And so these students, in Mon
Valley, and their teachers,
they created this ad hoc, duct
tape Roadtrip Nation
curriculum.
And the students were road
tripping around Western
Pennsylvania and Mon Valley, in
their own cars, on school
buses, just on day trips,
interviewing entrepreneurs,
local restaurateurs, the
taqueria owner, the guy who
started the movie store, local
small businesses, EMT
technicians.
And we had been somewhat
following this, but we were
more involved in our TV show
and that kind of a thing.
At the end of the year,
they flew us out.
And we walked into this
conference area, hall, where
there was hundreds of kids,
organized into teams of three,
showing off their projects,
with poster boards and
computers, with showing some of
the videos from their road
trips and the people
they'd interviewed.
And, at that moment, we knew
that we that we had stumbled
upon what we thought could be
the ultimate incarnation of
what the Roadtrip Nation
movement could be, which was
not only having people watch
the experiences of other
students, who were lucky go in
the green RV, but to actually
create the experience
themselves.
So in 2008, we launched
roadtripnation.org, as a
501(c)3 organization, that
creates curriculum and tools
and resources for teachers,
especially in low income
communities, to bring this
Roadtrip Nation experience to
their students.
So we're going to walk you
through a little bit of that
curriculum.
Before he keep going, is there
any quick questions on the
history of Roadtrip Nation or
how we got here, before we
dive into the education piece?
NATHAN GEBHARD: The real
exciting part.
AUDIENCE: You've become experts
on this topic, right?
Because you've had a movie, you
got a book, so people come
up to you and say, so what
should I do with my life?
You get this question.
So besides telling them that
they should be a product
manager at Google, what
else do you tell them?
MIKE MARRINER: Be a product
manager at Google.
I think you guys hit
the jackpot.
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think we
really try not to be the
experts in anything.
I think, for us, it wasn't
about people
telling us what to do.
I mean, I think everybody
can relate to that.
To discover your own road, to
make it for yourself, that
matters so much more than
somebody coming down and
saying, you know, you
look like you'd
make a great plumber.
And so for us, our whole
experience is
about sharing stories.
And so it's not for us to become
the experts on career
exploration.
It's for us to present the
avenue and the opportunity to
explore, for the individual, and
for that person to define
their own road.
So experts of none, maybe.
AUDIENCE: Did you make the cold
calls before the trip, or
you were calling people
along the trip?
BRIAN MCALLISTER: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
We made all the cold calls.
And we actually booked all the
interviews before we left.
AUDIENCE: How many?
How many were there?
BRIAN MCALLISTER: 84
interviews total.
So we had a lot of intention.
It wasn't like we were nomads
just kind going with the wind,
and wherever we end
up, we end up.
We had a lot of intention.
I think it was a lot to just
prove to our parents that we
had a project happening.
As you guys can remember, at
that age, when people are--
your parents.
And we had a lot of pressure
from like, what are you guys
going to do?
And we really felt that we
wanted to have that intention
lined upfront.
And once we start booking
interviews, we really needed
to schedule all that
out, right?
So once we landed an interview
with Justice Sandra Day
O'Connor, then we wanted to
interview some other folks.
You really started to build
out the itinerary.
And that actually really
built a lot of
momentum for our project.
AUDIENCE: How did you screen
out the 84 people?
BRIAN MCALLISTER: Yeah, it's
kind of a self-selecting
prophecy, almost.
A lot of people said, no.
We got rejected a lot.
And the people that we accepted
was really based on,
they remembered a time,
in their life, that
they were like us.
And so it's almost
like giving back.
And I think that was one of the
biggest things, why people
said, well, how do a couple
scrappy kids, out of college,
book some of these interviews
with Michael Dell or Howard
Schultz, the chairman of
Starbucks, or the hair stylist
to Madonna and Lenny Kravitz?
Honestly, they remember the time
in their lives that they
could have used some
of the advice that
they were giving us.
They identified with us.
And I think, once they saw us,
that age and that turmoil or
that ambiguity creeped back in,
saying, wow, I wish I had
someone that would have put
some advice on my table.
And so they really identified
with the age and our
situations that we were
going through.
MIKE MARRINER: And we've seen
that with the students today,
who are going through
the curriculum.
So over the last 3 years, over
100,000 students have gone
through the Roadtrip Nation
Experience curriculum, on a
high school level.
And it's the same thing.
Our first pilot ever, for the
curriculum, was in Fresno, in
a corner of Fresno called Orosi,
California, southeast
Fresno County.
And a lot of the students there
and the teachers and the
school district at first was
like, who are they going to
interview in Orosi,
there's no one.
There's no Michael Dell
here or whatever.
But what we realize is that
their are leaders in
everyone's community.
When you localize it, those
conversations become even more
relevant and more impactful,
because there's a gap in
social capital we've seen a
lot of communities, where
students, from a certain part of
Orosi, may not have access
to interviewing even EMT
technicians or local lawyers
or local government officials.
One team, from Fresno,
interviewed
the mayor of Fresno.
And to them, the mayor of Fresno
was like Barack Obama.
That was like the biggest
deal ever.
And one of the most impactful
interviews we've ever seen was
in our first pilot.
Some of the students there
interviewed a gang violence
activist, in southeast Fresno
county, who was in one of the
earliest Central California
gangs, was put in prison years
when he was like 19 years old,
got out on early parole,
because he worked off
some of his time.
And now he's giving back
to his community.
But to him, to those students,
that issue of gang violence is
so central, in the California
Central Valley, that that was
their Michael Dell and to have
them localize that experience.
And so what we've seen is that
now the students are doing the
cold calling.
And that's part of
the curriculum.
And so, actually, why don't we
just jump into showing a
little except of
the curriculum.
But this was one of the big
humps we had to get through
from Roadtrip Nation, which
was how do you scale the
impact of this experience?
We know that providing a
transformative experience by
helping students to get outside
of their comfort zone,
connecting with leaders is a
huge way to help students
figure out what they want
to do with their lives.
But being in the green RVs
is obviously limiting.
And so what we did was-- if you
can click on the lessons
and projects, the table
of contents.
So this is essentially
roadtripnation.org.
There's a roadtripnation.com,
which is our public television
focused site and college
programs and
student facing site.
Roadtripnation.org is the
educational resources that
school districts bring into
the classroom as a project
based learning curriculum.
It's been aligned to the
Educational Standards for
English Language Arts.
So it's like official on the
back end and funded by the
California Department of
Education and the Hewlett
Foundation.
But on the front end, it feels
student based and exactly like
you would feel if you're living
in the motor home for
three months.
So it's kind of a window into
what we hope is the future of
education, which is more for
students, by students
curriculum and programming
that really empowers and
galvanizes students on the front
end, rather than just
like hitting them with standards
and tests and
rubrics on the back end,
focusing more upstream on the
more self-efficacy, student
agency side of the equation,
that will then help
them to engage.
And then you start to see some
of those outcomes downstream,
rather focusing it the
other way around.
So essentially, the curriculum
is a three part curriculum.
Part one is called exposure.
Part two is called
self-construction.
And part three is the
Roadtrip project.
Part three is the component
where it's the big culminating
piece of actually going out,
in their communities, and
building these projects.
But we knew, with a lot of the
populations that we were
serving, having them to
basically build a Roadtrip is
kind of like, sure, right.
I'm going to go cold call the
mayor of my local town or like
an EMT technician.
We realized we needed to
have some exploratory
experience up front.
So for part one, what we did
was we had our staff go
through the entire interview
archive, of 1,100 interviews
over the last 10 years,
and start to take that
ethnographic approach of,
essentially, boiling down the
common themes and insights of
how these leaders have figured
out what they wanted to
do with their lives.
We then took those themes and
boiled them down to what we
call the seven core axles of
Roadtrip Nation, which are
these real life insights, in
terms of how people have
figured out what they wanted
t do with their life.
So if you didn't grow up with
Howard Schultz as your dad or
someone who had these incredible
insights, this is a
way to boil that down.
And then each lesson--
like making it work,
we're going to
play here in a second--
is essentially boiled down into
these topical lessons,
from the archive, along
this theme.
So we're going to play one
sample lesson here, which is
making it work, which we heard
time and time again.
This is a perfect commonality.
Finding your road in life
is not always easy.
It's not like you just
stick it, find your
dream, and make it happen.
Along the way, there are
lots of potholes.
Being a bartender to pay
off financial aid.
So here's an example
of that theme.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What I did is a series
of many odd jobs.
I worked in a music store.
I did all of these different
jobs, none of which were very
gratifying.
And at night, I did what I
really wanted to do, which was
watch television and think about
it and have opinions and
bore people with my opinions
about what I thought.
Over time, it just became
apparent that, gee, I seem to
know a lot about that or at
least I believed that I did.
So I found myself
at a TV network.
I took a massive pay cut
to deliver mail.
And it really wasn't mail.
They could have told me, we want
you to dig holes out in
the backyard, or we want
you to tie string
together all day long.
But if there were TV monitors
in the vicinity, I would've
been happy.
-[SPUTTERING ENGINE]
-Is that getting worse?
-Yeah, we've put about
10,000 miles on it
in the past 6 weeks.
-Well, I'd have to say major
engine work, from listening to
that, to be honest with you.
-Shh, it's OK.
-I think it's just gone.
It's on its last legs.
-Look, unless someone's handing
you something, right
after you get out of school,
it's going to be tough for the
first couple of years.
I've slept in every rest stop
along the Jersey turnpike.
I had an alarm clock,
a comforter, and a
pillow in the back.
I put my seat on recline.
I had a portable toothbrush.
I would take a bird bath
in the bathroom.
I would show up at the radio
station, here, in New York,
and I would do my shift.
-I ate, you know, in rotation,
tomato soup and SpaghettiOs
and tuna fish, every
day for a year.
-Average day, I'd do
18 to 20 hour days.
-The first five years of this
job were really, really
emotionally difficult for me.
And so I remember going home, on
the train, my first years--
I shouldn't admit
this on camera--
crying a lot, because
it was so difficult.
-I used to sit in my dorm, my
freshman year, I was so afraid
to leave to go brush my teeth,
that I would wait until I
heard everyone was sleeping, at
like 2:30-3:00 AM, just to
go brush my teeth, so I could
run back into my room.
I was petrified of people.
But I did have my dream of
being a broadcaster.
And that's what kept
me on my path.
-You might live in
an apartment that
is the size of this.
You might not be able to
afford to buy clothes.
None of that stuff
is important in
your grinding years.
The things that you learn about
yourself on the way are
the most important things.
-Ah, I got to go, got
to go, got to go.
Every second that we try to find
this place, we're taking
time off the interview.
-I drew for hours and endless
hours, every day, without
fault, every day, seven days a
week, until I got my portfolio
pages right.
But what happened was that I
was working at a lighting
design store.
And a guy comes in who needed
some lighting for his studio.
I asked him what kind
of art he does.
And he says, well,
I work in comics.
And I said, do you know anybody
at DC or at Marvel? he
says I know one guy at DC.
He was just hired there.
He's a brand new editor,
so don't expect a lot.
So I went down there
with my portfolio.
And the editor wouldn't even
see me in his office.
So he met me in the lobby.
And he's like, all right,
what have you got, kid?
What have you got?
And I opened up my portfolio.
And he's like, holy mackerel,
this is good.
He's like, wait here, right?
So he comes back.
He's like, listen, you're
broke, aren't you?
I'm like, yeah, I'm
pretty broke.
He's like, do an inventory
cover.
Here are three characters that
appear in this story.
Just give me a cover
with these three
characters, all right?
And come back when
you're finished.
I went home.
I finished the cover
overnight.
And I was at his doorstep,
at DC, first
thing in the morning.
Once again, he meets me in the
hallway, in the lobby.
He's like, what are
you doing here?
I'm like, here's your cover.
He's like, I didn't
need it overnight.
I'm like, here's your cover.
And he looks at me.
And I had these really
sad, puppy dog eyes.
And he's like, you need
a job, don't you?
I'm like, yeah.
He's like, man, I'm sorry.
I've got nothing.
But I'll tell you what.
Wait out here.
I'll ask around the office,
see if somebody's got
something but don't
hold your breath.
I'm like, OK.
So I'm literally sitting in the
lobby, it must have been
an hour plus.
And the receptionist picks
up the phone, and
she goes, OK, OK.
And she hangs up.
She's like, are you
Joe Quesada?
I'm like, yeah.
She's like, Mr. [? Alsey ?]
would like to
see you in his office.
I'm like, OK.
So I trot on over
to the office.
And I'll never forget this.
As long as I live, I will
never forget this.
I walk through the door.
And he looks at me.
He's like, what art the odds
that while you're waiting out
there, one of my two artists,
on my two books,
just calls and quits?
I'm like, it's pretty
astronomical.
He's like, what are the
odds that I'm going
to offer you a job?
I'm like, next to nil.
He's like, you want the job?
I'm like, sure.
-If you hadn't got that cover
done the night before?
-Exactly.
My whole life would be
completely different.
-That's incredible.
-I may have gotten a day job
that would've distracted me,
whatever it may be.
I firmly also believe though
that, if you have the desire
and the passion, which
I did, I would have
eventually broken in.
Some people are just incredibly,
naturally talented
and are born athletes or are
born singers or are born
artists and they can just, one
day, sit down and just do it.
But those are the one
in a kazillion that
can actually do that.
Everyone else on planet Earth
has to work really, really
hard for it.
-You know, as far as like
working, work ethic, you have
to work hard.
You know what I mean, like
always work hard?
Don't expect anybody to
give you anything.
-It's not like I walked into MTV
and I was like, whoo, I'm
directing two weeks later.
I mean, I worked my butt
off for a long time.
-If you think of your situation
as being like a
tripod, on three legs
that hit the ground.
And each of those
legs has a name.
And one of them is luck.
The other one is talent.
And the other one
is hard work.
Although one of those things
will get you into a situation,
as quickly as possible, you
have to get another one of
those tripod legs
on the ground.
-You just have to run at
something until something is
talking to your heart loudly
enough that you won't even
have to wonder if it's
the right thing.
But you have to run
pretty hard.
And you have to be a moron
along the way.
And you have to accept that
there's going to be a lot of
wasted time and energy and that
that is not a bad thing.
-It is more important to me to
fulfill this larger goal,
which I wanted Chicago to have
a Shakespeare theater.
And so I always came back to
that, in saying, you know
what, so you're crying.
So you had a horrible day.
But you're still doing something
that, if you left,
you might never forgive
yourself.
-There was something in me that
just said, you're not
going to fail.
It's just how long is it
going to be hard for?
-Like anything else in
life, it's a huge
roller coaster ride.
There can be high times, low
times, happy times, sad times.
-Will.i.am wore my shoe to,
I think, the BET Awards.
The shoe got on display
at the DNC.
And then like the first big
thing to happen was the
Smithsonian emailing me.
And I thought it was a joke.
I was saying, no.
I had to call the lady and
say, are you serious?
You want my shoe in the large
museum in the world, a painted
tennis shoe that I did?
And she was like,
yes, we want it.
It's beautiful.
And I cried.
I was like, I was almost
homeless in January.
Had I quit a month before I made
that shoe, if I quit an
hour before I made that shoe
and decided, I'm just going
forget my art, this would've
never happened.
I could've quit.
I was about to be kicked
out of my house.
And I didn't quit and then
look what happened.
-One thing that does give me
satisfaction, when I sit back
and think about what could have
happened, what if I'd
just got a job doing something
that I didn't enjoy and stayed
back in Boston and was with the
guys I grew up with and
didn't really evolve and grow
and change and be the person I
could've been?
That give me satisfaction, when
I look back and go, wow,
I don't even really work.
I'm doing what I love to do.
It's fun.
-The UG named me reporter
of the year, last year.
And I can't believe it.
I can't believe that I'm getting
to do exactly what I
wanted to do.
I'm seriously, seriously
living my dreams.
See, I'm getting emotional.
Because I really didn't think
this was going to happen.
And it's happening.
So to you guys, I say,
just keep fighting,
keep doing your thing.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE MARRINER: --a third
of the curriculum.
That's mostly based on the 10
years of Roadtrip Nation
content and interviews.
The curriculum culminates with
a project based learning
experience, where students
build their own
local Roadtrip projects.
And we're going to show you
one example video, now.
And this is the part that's been
really exciting for us.
Over the last three years, we've
had a 100,000 students
in schools, across 22 states,
building these Roadtrip
projects, as part of their
classroom assignments, mostly
in English language arts or
advisory periods, or 8th to
9th grade transition programs,
right at the point where a lot
of students are really in danger
of dropping out and
seeing the relevance of
why I'm in education
in the first place.
But here's an example.
And this is on YouTube.
So YouTube, we're also launching
some really new,
exciting partnerships with
YouTube, here at Google, which
is exciting, as well.
But here's an example of how
we started to see students,
cross the country, doing
Roadtrip Nation Projects and
releasing them through
YouTube.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-If you live in San Diego, you
know Sam, Sam the cooking guy.
A couple of Hoover students
decided to get the 411 on how
Sam got to be a local
TV celebrity.
This is our Roadtrip Nation
project, San Diego style.
-I was 40 when I figured
it out, 40.
I had no clue the rest
of the time.
And I did like five different
things trying to just keep
myself from going crazy
and figuring out how
to make some money.
But it took me to get to that
age before I finally went holy
[INAUDIBLE], this is like,
maybe this could work.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE MARRINER: Just to end on
impact, what we've been
learning, lately, in education,
is that you can't
just go into the education world
and say, we're going to
inspire people.
There's a responsibility, when
you're working with students,
especially students in the
communities where we work.
And so over the last year, the
Hewlett Foundation has funded
a third party efficacy study on
Roadtrip Nation's expansion
and proliferation through
these school systems and
trying to really ascertain,
what is the impact we're
really having on
these students?
And essentially, what
they've been
finding is that students--
through different modalities,
in terms of how they've
researched this--
self-efficacy rates, which is,
essentially, students'
self-belief in their ability to
solve complex problems and
more the non-cognitive senses,
in terms of their belief in
themselves and their futures,
have increased
at significant rates.
But also, their GPA rates
have been increasing.
So this study just came out
last week, by a Dr. David
[? Connelly ?].
But it found that students, in
a comparison study, in San
Jose Unified School District,
in credit recovery settings,
the most at-risk students,
when the Roadtrip Nation
students, over a nine month
period, had twice the rate of
GPA increase, when compared to
the non-Roadtrip students, in
the exact same socioeconomic
and demographic settings.
And the researcher said this
was interesting, because
Roadtrip Nation, nowhere in
our curriculum do we say,
study hard, get good grades,
follow the standards, all
those things.
It's all kind of connected to
the new common core standards
for ELA anchor standards on the
back end, so it's legit
from a district standpoint.
But we focus more on the
self-efficacy component.
Students taking ownership over
their futures and actually
being an active participant in
what they want to do with
their life.
And by focusing on those more
upstream, self-efficacy
factors, we start to see
downstream academic gain start
to increase.
It's an interesting part of
the journey for Roadtrip
Nation, because.
It is our 10th year anniversary
for Roadtrip Nation.
But we really feel like it's
beginning of an entire new 10
year chapter, where
were continuing to
proliferate the movement.
And we're just scratching the
surface on what we can do.
So we just want to thank you
guys for staying here for
lunch and listening
to our story.
And if you guys have any
questions, we're here to give
you a sense of how the heck
where we're doing this.
AUDIENCE: I had a quick question
about if you saw
difference, with the economy
going down and coming back up,
in this last 10 years, and
how that impacted your
conversations, with both the
people you're interviewing and
then the students?
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think it was
interesting, because, when we
started, it was just
before the crash.
And it was all like, every
single magazine, every
business cover was like how
to hire the best people.
And it was a totally, incredibly
competitive place.
But I think, as a young person
getting out of college and
trying to find that first job,
there was still that question
in your mind of like, do I take
that huge signing bonus,
salary job that my parents will
be really excited about?
Or do I take this thing that I
actually really care about?
And I think, regardless of the
economic times, those same
questions are asked.
And the realities, obviously,
are different.
And there's more compromise
that each of us, as
individuals, have to take
in certain situations.
But those fundamental questions,
of who am I and
what's important to me and do
I make these decisions for
myself or for other people, I
don't think those ever change.
BRIAN MCALLISTER: I would
also add, too--
and perhaps it's more of a
generational thing than an
economic crisis--
but people want to be involved
in mission-driven companies.
The mission-driven side,
CSR, corporate social
responsibility, starting
to become really hot.
And a lot of the generations
that we're working with, I
mean, the college students, they
really want to be a part
of something bigger, that was
sustainable, that had a
lasting impression, that had
a lasting footprint.
And I think that was something
that we were really hearing
from both sides.
And I think some of it was
probably driven from the
economic side.
But I think a lot of this
younger generation we're
working with, they want to be
a part of something that was
going last the test of time.
So I think mission-driven is
starting to become a pretty
big theme, as you guys know.
MIKE MARRINER: And that last
theme of making it work, we've
seen that be more pervasive
as well.
You can follow what it is you're
really passionate about
and define your own road.
But you've got to find a
way to make it work.
That's why that whole theme in
the curriculum was called,
making it work.
Because, essentially, you might
see someone who's the
director of "Saturday Night
Live," but what you also need
to hear is that she worked at
the Gap, for two years, during
the holidays, so she
could pay her rent.
Because she was getting
paid next to
nothing doing her thing.
And I'm sure even guys, like the
roots of Google, you see
this huge thing today.
But I'm sure, in the early
days, there was a lot of
making it work that had to
happen, whether it was
starting it out of a garage or
whatever, not being in this
big, fancy office building.
In America, we're so success
obsessed, in our culture, we
kind of forget those parts
of the story, like
the groveling periods.
And I think that we've really
tried to celebrate that with
Roadtrip Nation, where we're
looking back on these people
stories as like, these are the
grinding times, when, yes,
they may have taken a
really tough path.
But how do we inspire and
empower the next generation of
leaders, too?
Who's going to be the next
person that cures cancer?
What if there's a kid out there
who has a real genius
instinct for science, but who
never really connected with
that interest, because, A, there
was too much noise and
pressure around them to not go
away to college, to stay home
and be with family,
or, B, that it's
going to be too hard.
I don't want to make it work.
Getting my Ph.D.?
No freaking way.
I'm going to go do something
much easier.
So what we're trying
to is decipher all
these stories down.
And I think that, as culture
changes, there is some kind of
tonality shifts.
But I think, per Nate's point, a
lot of the core ethos remain
pretty consistent.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever thought
to expand this program
internationally?
MIKE MARRINER: Yes.
We have done a few international
Roadtrips.
We actually started to tone
it back a little bit, only
because we realized that
America is so big.
And now that we've really
gotten into the
heavy lifting work.
I mean, talk about hard work,
like education, that is really
hard, complicated,
incredible work.
And so when we started to see
how, over the last 3 years,
we've expanded to 22 states.
And that has taken
all of our focus.
So Roadtrip Nation, it's much
bigger than just Nate,
Brian, and I now.
We have 40 employees.
We have an office based down
in Southern California, in
Costa Mesa, right between
LA and San.
Diego and we have 40, totally
dedicated, passionate
individual who are building
this, editing the footage,
implementing the curriculum,
working with the schools,
researching the data,
all of that.
And so I think we've seen the
need to focus that effort,
domestically, for now.
But we do, ultimately, have a
vision of going to countries
around the world that really,
obviously, where their youth
are in high need of figuring
out what their
futures are as well.
AUDIENCE: To what degree have
you found that it's not just
adversity that people are
overcoming but also a sense of
diversity in their lives, or in
their work experience and
stuff like that, that's really
helped fuel them or push them
onto their ultimate careers?
NATHAN GEBHARD: Diversity?
In what sense do you mean?
AUDIENCE: Diversity and like
difference in things they've
done or experiences that
they've had and stuff.
Because I think we hear that
constant plea of follow your
passion and that
kind of thing.
But part of it is, sometimes,
people maybe--
it's not like they don't have
passions or particular
passions, but they don't really
know what their passion
is or where they would
find that.
So in experiencing a diverse
life or diverse jobs or a
diverse career paths and that
kind of thing can sometimes
lead you then to, eventually,
what it is
that you really love.
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think I would
say that diversity, that
ability and that comfort to kind
of just be OK wandering
is something that an
instructor or a
counselor or a parent--
it's hard advice to
give to somebody.
But I think, as we've
interviewed so many people,
that's the reality
of their life.
I mean I think that sense of
just bumping into things is a
really important part.
And I think what we've seen is
that the people that are
comfortable following their own
compass and then having
that diversity of experience,
those are the ones that start
on one thing and then realize,
oh, well, there's something
about this that's interesting.
And there's something
about this.
And if I put them together,
I'll get here.
But those that take that linear
path often miss those
other opportunities.
So I think some of the most
interesting people have been
comfortable wandering
and changing careers
and starting over.
And there's countless examples
of people that we've had that
have had that exact
experience.
AUDIENCE: I know you primarily
targeted schoolchildren and
people who were starting up.
What's your experience with
people who are in a midlife
crisis or who need to figure
out the next thing?
They had like a mindless,
corporate job for majority of
their lives.
Not Google, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
So what's your experience
been?
MIKE MARRINER: Our mission,
very intentionally, is to
empower people to define their
own roads in life.
We've only been really focusing
on students, because
they're so vulnerable at that
age, especially in certain
geographical locations
around America.
If you don't focus on some
demographics of students, like
the alternate thing is a student
that drops out of high
school is eight times as likely
to be more incarcerated
or living on welfare or to have
kids that are also on
welfare and be incarcerated.
But we hear, all the time,
because of the PBS series, the
demographic is a little
bit older.
And we hear, all the time, that
the message is timeless.
The messages is you don't just
define your own road in life
when you're 18 years old, and
then you like stick it, great,
no big deal.
Defining your own road
in life happens
throughout your entire life.
And so especially when you get
in your 30s, 40s, 50s and you
have this wealth of experience,
just kind of being
open and pliable and taking a
lot of these same ethos and
themes and applying them
to your own life.
Like Nate was saying, mashing
it up, having more
experiences, be comfortable
with wandering.
I think that we absolutely
see as a lifelong piece.
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think one
story that comes to mind is
the founder of Sam Adams.
He was a consultant.
And I think he was at Bain
Capital, I think.
MIKE MARRINER: Boston
Consulting Group.
NATHAN GEBHARD: Boston
And here he was, going
through the machine.
He was part of that machine.
And there are consultants that
absolutely love what they do.
But he just wasn't
one of them.
And when the Roadtrippers
were asking him like,
what about that risk?
You leave this really high
paying job, and you're going
to go brew beer in your
mom's kitchen?
And you watched him pause
for a while and
really think about it.
And I loved his reaction.
And his reaction was, the bigger
risk would have been
staying and doing something that
I didn't love then taking
this risk in brewing beer
in my mom's kitchen.
And I think that it's the
clarity and the confidence
that need to come together
in those moments.
And so the exposure we have is
that, while it's young people
roadtripping, we're talking
to people that
have figured it out.
So we're getting it
on both ends.
But that's an example
that comes to mind.
We can chill, too.
AUDIENCE: Why, I was going to
say, to close, what is the
number one tip you have for
driving an RV across your 10
years of experience?
MIKE MARRINER: RV driving
is a team sport.
That was our whole thing.
I think that our first road trip
prepared us for building
a business together.
Because if you can get a motor
home, especially a 30 year old
motor home, around the
country in one piece.
And the same thing, like when
you're driving down the road,
blind spot is an
understatement.
I mean you really can't see when
you're changing lanes.
So if you're going to change
lanes, it's like, I'm going to
change lanes.
So someone's out the window,
please, don't.
I'm coming in.
NATHAN GEBHARD: The oddest thing
is there's a rearview
mirror in an RV.
But you can't.
There's no.
You only look at the person
sitting on the
couch behind you.
BRIAN MCALLISTER: I would
say, don't wait
until you master it.
It's a work in progress.
And that might be
a deep metaphor.
But you got to hit the road,
sooner or later.
And I would say, don't wait
until you've got it all
figured out.
Because, when you get to Boston,
and there's no grids
there, you're screwed.
So just train as you go.
NATHAN GEBHARD: I would say be
comfortable getting lost.
I think that's something that
actually I have a complaint
about with the GPS is that
you don't get lost.
And the number of times that we
had meaningful experiences
when we just got lost.
We've lost those lost moments.
And so I think, in life or in
driving, get lost every once
in a while.
MALE SPEAKER: On that note,
thank you very much for
speaking with us today.
Amazing speech.
[APPLAUSE]